chez les du pif le rugby est une
tradition Mathieu suit les traces de son
père et de son oncle tous les deux
anciens piliers après des début en
Ardèche il joue sous les couleurs de la
SMB rugby pendant 3 ans trois saisons
qui vont être décisives bien encadré à
Montini matthie décolle et passe les
détections pour intégrer l'équipe cadet
du Stade Français en réalité quand il
est allé faire les détections il voulait
savoir s'il pouvait exister à ce
niveaau-là si avoir l'ambition d'être
dans un grand club avec une concurrence
exacerbée ce qui était pas le cas à
Montini il nétait pas dans une
concurrence exacerbée est-ce qu'il
arriverait à s'en sortir Mathieu vit 4 C
premiers mois très difficile mais il
s'accroche et finit par s'intégrer dans
l'effectif parisien les structures du
Stade Français ne pouvant accueillir
tous les matchs les Crabos les moins de
19 ans doivent jouer systématiquement
sur des pelouses différentes en ce
weekend de pâack Montini accueille la
rencontre face à Lille c'est très sympa
on avait joué un matchn dernière le 16e
de finale contre contre Massie on
l'avait joué ici aussi c'était très
sympa en plus a un super terrain vu que
c'est un terrain de foot donc il est pas
très abîmé il est bien entretenu et donc
bah ça fait plaisir de venir on est je
suis content mais ce retour sur ces
terre a un goût d'inachevé le pilier ni
monte un souffre d'une entorse à la
cheville gauche et doit regarder le
match des tribunes désormais bien
installé dans le groupe stadis depuis 3
saisons Matthieu reste très pragmatique
sur son avenir j'ai un niveau correct
certes mais pas forcément pour aller en
professionnel donc bah pour l'instant je
au Stade Français je suis content j'y
reste je vais continuer à Pier du temps
de jeu et à jouer le plus possible et
prendre du continuer à prendre du
plaisir puis après en seior on verra
peut-être j'iraai peut-être en 3e 4e
division pour jouer dans un dans un
autre club peut-être qui m'aidera à
faire mes études ensuite Mathieu dupf
prépare un baccalauréat scientifique
pour ensuite intégrer une faculté de
sport ah oui pour la petite histoire ces
coéquipiers se sont imposés 29 à 10 face
à
Lille